well it's not just free college and free
healthcare some 20 20 Democrats are
promising voters free cash cory booker
wants to give federally funded savings
accounts to every child when they're
born and andrew yang is promising
americans a thousand bucks a month
Kamala Harris is calling for massive tax
credits worth up to six thousand dollars
a year but it turns out these policies
don't work as promised surprise for
example New York City businesses are
struggling after hiking the minimum wage
to 15 bucks an hour so great the great
economist Milton Friedman said that if
the government was in charge of the
Sahara Desert they would eventually run
out of sand they think there's money for
everyone and that we're gonna pay for it
what do you think about their latest
cash push the great thing about
capitalism is that it can allow for a
little bit of socialism right it's
called the safety net it's safety net is
a bit of socialism you're giving
something to people who need something
my problem with these candidates right
now is they see the socialist part as a
replacement for the engine of creation
of wealth therefore you can never it's
like they think that you can have the
life preserver without the lifeguard
but the lifeguard throws the life
preserver out there so the thing is
capitalism plus safety net awesome
socialism as the safety net Venezuela
but Jesse doesn't be socialism part just
a little bite eventually take over the
entire system because it runs a
situation where the government and these
politicians say they're going to give
you money but they're that means they're
taking money from other people in order
to give you $1,000 a month or the tax
credit that you want well yeah socialism
they say that's to take care of you but
they're really just trying to take
control of you because if everybody
depends on the government for everything
health care a house a job college then
there's no room to breathe and you have
to then vote for the party in power
because that's who's giving you all of
your lifestyle at that point and then
when the Socialists take control they
destroy their opposition that's what
socialism does once the Socialists take
power it creates a permanent ruling
class and then they can get rid of oil
and gas they can get rid of the borders
they can get rid of capitalism then get
rid of religion they can get any
obstacle and you've seen it happen right
now because if you oppose socialism they
will Docs you they will censor you and
they will
boycott you and that's a threat but to
Greg's point about the safety net some
of the greatest inspirational creations
and innovations have come from people
that you know maybe we're living
paycheck to paycheck and maybe took a
risk here because they wanted to lift
themselves up and maybe not sleep on
their friend's couch and that's how
America and entrepreneurialship works is
because people go out there on a limb
and maybe borrow some money or raise
some money or put all of their money
into one pot and say this is all I have
because I believe in this idea so true
and then that's when you build wealth
and if you have socialism you don't get
that people are too comfy you know who
has a story like that Howard Schultz he
does founder of Starbucks grew up in the
Brooklyn housing project so now he's a
billionaire but Donna in the last debate
we definitely saw this rift on display
between Democrats who still believe in a
justifiable small safety net for people
who need it and then people like Andrea
and Cory Booker and Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie Sanders who really want to give
away everything based on policies they
say will tax the rich well you know
clearly I listen to these debates and I
say well that's an interesting proposal
I don't look at these debates and say my
god this is a socialist I see what no
what I see is is a country struggling to
figure out one how to make sure that
every American get a head start in a
healthy start in life a two how do we
ensure that every American not just
those who are wealthy and well-off have
an opportunity to have a fair shot at
the middle class and then lastly you
know when we spend government money the
deficit is now at thirty thirty nine
percent we know spending is up we know
that corporate tax receipts are down we
know a lot about Greg and I were talking
in agree room today about the tariffs
and how we want to get into a big
Lorde's conversation about China and the
tariffs
but when Democrats proposed these ideas
and once upon a time Republicans used to
propose ideas that people thought was
off to quote unquote change Nixon
created the Environmental Protection
Agency I can tell you a lot about George
Bush from Ronald Reagan we don't have
enough time but when Democrats proposed
these ideas they're trying to find ways
to level the playing field and why make
certain people uncomfortable I
I supported and worked and
for Al Gore and Bill Clinton who brought
the deficit down who tried to pay for
everything I listened to Democrats who
come forward with ideas that they can
pay for not simply to give away but if
we can pay for it it's an idea that we
should see if others Dayna it's been
interesting to see that there are
government private public partnerships
when it comes to some of these programs
right so the Trump administration has
done a lot on on jobs private public
partnerships those are things that maybe
get an infrastructure bill done too but
then there's opposition to that but I
think that the bottom line is no one
thinks that they're going to lose an
election by promising to spend more
money it just depends on what how you're
gonna spend the money and president like
we know that we need to do something
about Medicaid and Medicare and Social
Security going forward there are ways to
do that with it where the bite wouldn't
be too much but you could preserve that
program for a long time no one is
talking about that right now because
it's a political loser and the other
thing is just remember the majority of
people in America are fiscally liberal
and socially conservative it's not the
other way around people think it's the
other way it's not but Dana's here to
tell you the truth